that in the second quarter leading up to
your
ejection as far as you were tripping at
at Scott Foster a bit so I was just
wondering you know KD Drew contact he
went to the line and you were yeah is
it's
personal yeah we had a situation some
years ago and it's personal you know
what I mean
like the league know everybody know it's
been a meeting and all that and it's
just a situation with my son and so
it's yeah
we yeah so I'm I'm okay with a ref
talking you know saying whatever saying
just don't use a tech to get your point
across you know what I mean
so I got to do a better job making sure
I stay on the floor for my teammates but
yeah that's that's that you said there's
a situation with your son yeah they know
what it is he know what it is too so
we don't know what it
is yeah it's just know I had a meeting
with him my dad Doc Rivers BYOB belany
and all us
so yeah yeah him too is that back in
when you were with youou with the
Clippers
so did you come out of that picking it
was a whole thing man but it's it's
still been a thing for a while wow
so I ain't saying nothing to get fined
huh
yeah yeah it is what it is at this
point what were your feelings at the
beginning of the game when you heard the
Roar from the crowd after your trippy
video tribute
video they run a video like like a
minute or two before tip off just say
welcome back Chris and thanks for all
you
man that's CRA I'm I'm in the back
yeah well damn I appreciate it you know
what I mean like for real man this fan
base is amazing to to me and my family
you know what I mean every game like 7
minutes on the clock I'm in the back I'm
trying to get this engine started for
the game but um man I I appreciate them
wholeheartedly seriously I had three
amazing years
here I can ask one more about inent were
you look like you were surprised at the
second did you think it was done after
yeah that's what I'm saying if you going
to pop your you know what I'm
saying don't don't use a tech to get
your point across you know what I'm
saying that's the only thing with it you
know we we had these conversations all
the time there's some officials that'll
talk back to you and stuff like that
which is sometimes it's healthy it's an
intense game you know you go back and
forth but it's like some po like you
just going to you get to give a tech to
get your point AC cross you know what
I'm saying so at that point though when
something was said I I ain't care no
more you know
so is what it is sure I see him in a
game seven
soon that's how it always works out with
him just one more on that you mentioned
trying to make a point what point do you
think he's trying to make to you I don't
know he got the power cuz he can call a
tech you know what I'm saying so that's
how it's been for a long time you know
what I mean
he I ain't going to go there let me
chill um yeah you got they say the judge
jury
and
yeah